Obviously, it helps to be an animal lover
when you start working at a shelter.
It’s not exactly a requirement of the job,
but it definitely makes it more palatable
when you occasionally have to deal with a
critter that’s more nasty than usual.
Having an already built-in compassion towards
animals makes it easier to forgive them for
not doing what you want.
From a very young age, Harper always liked
to think of animals as people, they just didn’t
think or communicate the same way as humans.
Even the best-trained pets in the world don’t
really know the actual meaning of certain
words, they’re just taught how to respond
to specific commands in certain ways.
But that doesn’t mean that they couldn’t
also have distinct personalities of their
own, just like humans do.
And then, of course, there were all the wild
animals that had never been trained or domesticated.
Harper always felt a little sorry for any
baby bird with its wing broken or any badgers
or opossum that arrived at the shelter after
getting hit by a car.
They didn’t live around humans and had probably
never even experienced being indoors before,
let alone having people nursing them back
to health.
To empathize, Harper used to imagine how terrified
she would be if she was hurt – if she’d
broken her leg or arm or worse – only for
something much larger than her to take her
into a structure she’d never been in before.
And on top of that, having no way of understanding
that this giant was trying to help her heal,
as well as being separated from her friends,
family, and everyone she knew.
The way she saw it, that was what it must’ve
been like for the majority of animals that
were brought into the shelter where she worked,
and she wanted to do her best to help calm
her little furry or feathered patients.
“You’ve got to fortify your heart in this
job, Harp,” her friends who worked with
her at the shelter would say.
And it was true to an extent.
They didn’t mean she had to become cold
and heartless, that would be an overcorrection.
But it was their – and Harper’s – responsibility
to administer the appropriate medical care
and provide a temporary sanctuary to these
lost, wounded or abandoned animals.
What Harper had to remember was, that none
of them were her own pets.
Often, a lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone else’s
companion and might have just got lost while
out on a walk.
And while some others were given up by their
previous owners who had cruelly shrugged off
the responsibility of caring for them, those
animals were in need of new homes, and couldn’t
stay cooped up in the shelter forever.
Not everyone that gave up their pet did it
callously though.
Sometimes they might have found themselves
falling on hard times and being unable to
financially look after an animal.
Others might have owned a pet that had a behavioral
problem – like being too aggressive – and
even though the person still loved them dearly,
they might have just not been able to make
it work.
In times like that, they’d have no choice
but to take their animal to the shelter.
Just outside the side entrance was an area
where people could drop their animals off
and quickly buzz to the staff inside, just
in case they wanted to avoid a protracted,
emotional farewell to their four-legged or
winged companion.
The buzzer had sounded, just as Harper had
been coming off her lunch break.
It was her turn, this shift, to quickly go
and collect any animal that had been left
out there.
Even though their owners usually left them
in their cage or with their lead tied to a
nearby street lamp, Harper knew she had to
rush to the side door, just in case somebody
else tried to rush in and steal the poor,
abandoned pet.
After turning them in the lock, she hooked
her keys back on the belt clip she wore and
pushed the side door open.
Harper had been fully expecting to see the
usual, a leashed dog or cat coming over to
investigate her, confused as to where their
former owner had gone.
This time though, there was just a box standing
outside.
It wasn’t huge, in fact, it was almost entirely
empty…
almost.
Picking it up carefully, in case there were
baby birds or a nest of unhatched eggs inside,
Harper opened the cardboard flap to reveal…
a rock.
Sitting in the box was a single, solitary
rock, an oval of smooth granite, with a paper
note next to it.
Reaching in, she retrieved and unfolded the
scrap.
‘Please care for my pet rock’ was written
on one side, in a messy, uncoordinated scrawl.
Immediately assuming that this whole thing
was some kid’s idea of a joke, Harper tipped
the rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash.
She had more important things to focus on;
within the next hour alone, people brought
a concussed parakeet, a bat infected with
rabies, and a squirrel that had survived being
run over by a moped into the shelter.
Work had been so busy that, by the time her
shift had ended, Harper had barely thought
about the pet rock prank.
That is, until she was getting ready to leave.
She headed through the side door, mainly so
she could do a final check, in case any animals
had been left there and someone had forgotten
to hit the buzzer.
There was nothing there, and Harper hooked
her bag over her shoulder, shutting the door
behind her.
Something the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot, causing her to look
down and see the rock, the same one from earlier.
Only now, it had flipped over, probably after
she had tipped it out of its box.
On the side facing up at her, the rock had
a shiny metal zipper, fastened shut.
Curious, Harper picked it up to take a closer
look.
It didn’t seem like the zip had just been
glued onto the stone surface, it was embedded
in it, actually part of the rock itself.
And there was something… sad about it.
Sure, it was just a rock, an inanimate lump
of stone.
But for whatever reason, a feeling of pity
crept up on Harper, causing her to slip the
rock into her bag as she headed for the parking
lot.
It was starting to get dark by the time she
got home.
Heading up to her room and flipping on her
lamp, Harper placed the zipped-up stone under
its light and took another long look at it.
Although she’d first thought it was purely
a joke, now she couldn’t tell if it was
some elaborate art piece or a quirky garden
ornament.
The thing was solid stone all the way through,
surely the zipper was just for show.
There couldn’t possibly be anything beneath
it…
To her surprise, the metal fastener began
to part as Harper dragged on the puller and
slider down from the top stop towards the
bottom one.
It was relatively easy, not even some of her
own clothes unzipped as smoothly as this rock.
As soon as the slider connected with the bottom
stopper, the teeth of the top and bottom edges
parted, revealing more teeth below…
except these almost looked like human teeth.
They opened up to reveal a mouth, a part of
the rock just like the zipper which took the
place of its lips.
The moment the mouth opened, it let out a
tiny sound, like it was breathing, which startled
Harper.
With a yelp, she dropped the rock from her
hands and it even made a tiny grunt as it
fell to the floor.
It was alive.
Seeing it hit her bedroom carpet, Harper stared
utterly bewildered at the rock.
Its toothy mouth almost looked sad, like it
had curved into a frowning expression.
Then she heard the sound it was making.
Perhaps it was her years working with animals
at the shelter and her long-held sympathy
for them that had given her a sort of protective
instinct for all living things.
Or maybe it was just the bizarreness of the
situation, of having a rock with a mouth whimpering
in pain on the floor in front of her.
Either way, Harper felt compelled to pick
the lump of stone back up, and place it gently
on the desk.
Its mouth seemed to smile a bit more as she
did; while it seemed creepy at first, the
compulsion to take care of this helpless little
rock only got stronger.
Grabbing a pipette and pouring a glass of
water from the faucet, Harper started to squeeze
out droplets of water into the rock’s mouth.
She had no idea how it was able to drink,
but that didn’t seem all that important
or relevant in order for her to care for it.
After all, every time a parrot or duck or
crow was brought into the station, the procedure
was similar.
Harper would have to pipette them water or
medicine, it didn’t matter how they drank
it just because they had beaks.
It was the same with baby animals, puppies
and kittens especially, who might need bottle
feeding if they were only a few weeks old.
As much as she was starting from scratch and
would normally be completely baffled as to
the best way she could care for a rock, right
now Harper was pulling on her experience at
the shelter to nurse it back to health.
If she was, in fact, using her instincts and
not being…
influenced, somehow.
Over the next few days, Harper looked after
her newfound patient as if it had been her
lifelong pet.
As to why she was taking such care of a rock
or even what she would eventually do with
it, Harper didn’t really have much of a
clue.
But the answers to those questions didn’t
feel as important as looking after the rock.
She’d leave for work in the morning, only
to count down the hours through her shift
until she got to go home and tend to the smiling
stone.
Throughout the course of her working day,
she would pocket supplies to help her take
better care of her new ‘pet’; everything
from medicine in case it got sick or picked
up an infection of some kind, to bandages
and other materials she could use as bedding.
Grabbing a fresh, clean plastic container
for it instead of another cardboard box, Harper
was gradually fashioning a nest for the toothy
pebble.
And for the most part, it seemed to be working,
some deep-seated feeling told her that her
efforts to look after the rock was gradually
making it feel better every day…
And then it started talking.
It wasn’t exactly articulate or eloquent,
it didn’t even seem to know that many words,
other than the two it was weakly repeating
when she came home from work one day.
“Need… eat…” it rasped, a hoarse whisper
passing through its unzipped lips.
Rushing over to it, barely questioning it,
Harper tried filling up her pipette and giving
it more water.
The rock spat it back out, before speaking
again.
“No drink…
only eat…”
“What am I meant to feed you?”
she asked, once again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock.
Maybe at this point, after getting over the
fact it had a mouth, it wasn’t much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice.
Or could her compelling need to care for it
made her oblivious to the strangeness of this
situation?
Of course, this wasn’t a situation that
many people had also found themselves in.
This meant that even a quick cursory internet
search for ‘what do pet rocks eat’ didn’t
yield many useful results, only a few joke
articles and nothing that actually gave Harper
an answer she could act on.
All the while, her rock was still croaking
out the same two words, repeating them on
a loop, its little voice getting more and
more forceful each time.
“Need… eat…
Need eat!”
Low on options, Harper left some bread crusts
in the rock’s nest, hoping that would be
enough to at least sate the rock’s obvious
hunger.
It paused, either smelling or sensing that
it had been offered something to eat.
“Feed…” it rasped, before opening its
mouth wide with a tiny, expectant ‘ahh’.
Picking up the crusts one by one, Harper broke
little pieces off and fed each bit to her
rock.
She sighed as a sense of overwhelming relief
came flooding over her, glad that she’d
found a way to feed the mouthy little mineral.
If only it had worked for longer.
Only a few hours later, Harper was met with
more scraping demands from her pet rock, the
insistent sound waking her up in the middle
of the night.
But this time, as she offered it more bread
scraps, it refused to eat them.
It was still the early hours of the morning
by the time that Harper had gotten through
offering the rock every different type of
food in her kitchen, eventually giving up
through sheer exhaustion.
She folded her pillow over her ears, trying
to drown out the constant cries of:
“Need… eat…”
But it didn’t do enough to allow her to
get to sleep.
At any rate, the feeling that she had to care
for this talking rock was keeping her awake
as much as the noise.
Staring across the room, purposely facing
away from her pet rock, Harper’s eyes fell
over her work uniform.
The logo of the animal shelter stitched on
it was just about visible as the gentle glow
of street lamps bled through the curtains.
And seeing it, along with her keys clipped
onto her belt that lay on the floor, gave
her an idea that might work.
Desperation and the need to sleep getting
the better of her, Harper climbed in her car,
having put a jacket and jeans over her pajamas.
The streets were all empty at this hour, almost
pitch dark and deathly silent, but it made
driving from her home to workplace a lot faster
than usual.
All the while, the rock’s voice was getting
more and more demanding from its container
that she had strapped to the front passenger
seat.
Sneaking up to the side door, Harper turned
her key in the lock, pulled it open, and slipped
indoors.
The moment they heard the sound of the door
shutting, a number of the dogs that had been
resting securely in their cages woke up and
started barking, the noise loudly echoing
around the shelter.
Even though it drowned out the rock’s tiny
voice, it felt as if its words were still
ringing in Harper’s ears, compelling her
to go through with something she really didn’t
want to.
And yet, it felt like one of the only other
options she had left.
She’d decided it would have to be the squirrel,
rationalizing the choice in her head.
In an unpleasant but purely calculated, logic-based
way, it made the most sense.
Earlier that week, the bushy-tailed woodland
forager had been hit by a moped, it had barely
survived given the number of its tiny bones
that had been broken in the force of the impact.
Finding its cage, it was still asleep, heavily
sedated on the dosage of painkillers the shelter’s
resident vet had given it.
Gently scooping it out of the cage, feeling
its fur against her cupped hand, Harper looked
at her pet rock, its container on the table.
She remembered that it liked to be fed directly.
Swallowing an urge to be sick that was rising
at the back of her throat, Harper opened a
drawer in the vet’s office and pulled out
a surgical scalpel.
When her boss at the shelter heard there had
been a break-in and reviewed the footage on
the building’s security cameras, they were
shocked at what they saw.
Though the angle obscured what Harper was
doing, the blood leftover and one missing
squirrel seemed to be enough to go on.
That, coupled with the fact that she had broken
in after hours and the numerous supplies that
had gone missing from the storage cupboard,
led to Harper being dismissed.
She was fired from her job at the animal shelter,
forced to hand over her keys and uniform.
While any other day this would have devastated
her, the events seemed to wash over Harper
pretty quickly.
She was more relieved – no, pleased with
herself – that the rock had stopped begging
her to be fed.
Her plan had worked… for now.
It took about a week for her pet rock to start
demanding food again.
This time, just the sound of its voice made
Harper frantic.
Any ordinary human food she offered wasn’t
enough, it didn’t want that.
She already knew exactly what it wanted, the
only thing she’d fed it that had sustained
it.
The big problem was that now she didn’t
have her keys, it would be near impossible
for her to get into the shelter again.
Yet still, the forceful command to fed kept
up, day and night, hour after hour.
Until…
Harper considered the only thing she had left
to give her pet rock.
Lifting it out of the warm nest she kept it
in, her fingers were gripping the smooth stone
tightly.
Her arm was tense, in fact, both were; one
as her muscles strained while she held the
rock, the other in anticipation.
Hovering it above her opposite arm, Harper
could feel the tiny breaths of her pet against
her skin, almost like it was so excited to
eat again that it was panting with expectancy.
She put it back down on her desk, quickly
running into the bathroom.
It wasn’t that she had changed her mind
– she couldn’t, all she knew was that
she had to feed her pet rock.
Harper just needed to grab a cloth to put
in her mouth, clamping her jaws down on it
to muffle her scream as she let the rock’s
teeth sink into her flesh, blood trickling
down her arm.
Nobody saw much of Harper afterwards, her
friends from the shelter would continuously
call her cell phone, only to get no reply.
She barely paid any attention to the ringing,
eventually just letting her phone’s battery
die and not even bothering to charge it back
up.
It wasn’t important; to her, the only thing
that mattered was caring for her pet rock.
In Harper’s head, it needed to be kept safe
– and fed – and it was her job to look
after it to the best of her ability.
She had enough leftover medical supplies that
she’d lifted from the shelter – bandages,
antiseptic spray, rubbing alcohol, tranquilisers
– to treat her wounds.
After a while, it almost stopped hurting.
Knowing that she was helping keep her pet
rock fed, being so emotionally attached to
it made any of the pain more bearable.
Even when she woke up one morning to find
that her rock had rolled off her desk onto
her bed, it hardly phased her.
Nor did seeing it had gradually eaten her
leg during the night, gnawing through tendons
and bone as she slept, leaving her sheets
still slick with blood when she awoke.
Despite having lost most of her capacity for
rational thought, Harper decided it would
be best to plan ahead for when she was gone.
She knew, through some twisted form of logic,
that she wasn’t going to last forever.
There was only so much of her; she’d only
be able to feed her pet rock for so long.
Harper held a pen in her hand as best she
could with all the fingers she was now missing.
She scrawled out a note to whoever found what
was left of her, in messy, uncoordinated handwriting.
‘Please care for my pet rock.’
If keeping an SCP as a pet is an idea that
appeals to you, but you want one that doesn’t
come with the added danger of eating you alive,
then why not go and check out “SCP-529 JOSIE
THE HALF CAT”.
Or, if you aren’t really a cat person – or
a half-cat person – but still want to adopt
your own anomaly, then we might just have
the perfect list of candidates in “TOP FOURTEEN
FRIENDLIEST SCPS”.